네 여러분들 저는 역삼역에 왔습니다
역삼역 상권 같은 경우에는 테란로
중심으로 만들어진 업무 지구입니다
1990년대에 이제 이쪽에 회사
사업이라는 그리고 금융 기간들이 많이
몰려들었고 최근에는 이쪽에 스타트업
거리도 조성되고 스타트업들이 많이
몰려오면서 강남 전체적으로 봤을 때
직장인들이 가장 많은 어 그런
상권입니다 그래서 역삼역 상권 같은
경우에는 정말 사람이 많아요 특히
이제 직장인들이 많아서 평일 같은
경우에는 점심 시간만 조금 지날수록
식당에 들어가 할 수 없을 정도로
사람이 많습니다 그리고 이제 점심뿐
아니라 저녁에도 유동 인구가 굉장히
많은 그런 상권입니다 그리고 지금
테란로 근처 같은 경우에는 일반 상업
지역이어서 유흥 시설 허가가
나오거든요 그래서 직장인들이 이런
유흥 시설을 이용하는 경우가 많습니다
평일 점심뿐만 아니라 저녁 그다음에
이제 유흥 시설까지 정말 많은 시간이
활성화돼 있는 어 그런 상권이라고
보시면 되고 집 앞에 있는 배우 세대
같은 경우에는 이제 9투 6
시간대에는 사람이 없잖아요 평일에
주말에도 이제 외곽에 가거나 어디
이동해서 상권을 이용하는 경우가
많아서 배우 상권보다는 개인적으로
제가 봤을 때 직장인 상권이 더
탄탄하고 안전하다고 생각을 합니다
근데 단점은 뭐냐면 평일 같은
경우에는 직장인들이 굉장히 많이
있지만 주말에는 사람이 없어요 여기
인근에 뭐 배우 세대 사람으로만
상권이 이용되 기에는 좀 한계가 있다
보니까 주말 같은 경우에는 역삼역뿐만
아니라 성능력 아지도 사람이 없습니다
주말에 사람이 워낙 없다 보니까
주말에는 문 닫는 가게들도 꽤 있어요
평일 장사만 한다라는 얘기가 있을 정
정도로이 역삼역을 평일에 직장인들을
위한 그런 상권이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 근데 특이한게 강남역 상권
같은 경우에는 주말에가면 더 많아요
평일뿐만 아니라 주말에도 사람이
많은데 그 이유가 뭐냐면 웬만한
경기도 아니면 인천 뭐 수도권 가는
버스가 다 이어져 있습니다 많은
사람들이 강남역을 기준으로 약속
장소를 많이 잡거든요 직장인들뿐만
아니라 젊으신 분들 아니면 좀 연세가
있으신 분들도 강남역 상권을 이용하기
때문에 주 7일 상권이라고 보시면 될
거 같습니다네 그리고 강남역 같은
경우 에는 지금이 상권뿐만 아니라
최근에 병원들도 많이 생겼어요 병원을
이용하려고이 강남역으로 오는 경우도
되게 많아졌고 외국인 관광객 수요도
많이 옵니다 관광 명소가 될 정도로
외국인 관광객도 이렇게 강남역을 많이
찾는다고 보시면 될 거 같고 최근에
특이한 경험을 했는데 국기연 언덕길에
엄청 높은 곳에서 프로필 사진을
찍었는데 사람이 바글바글 한 거예요
5분에게 이렇게 사진 촬영할 정도로
그만큼 사람이 많이 있었습니다 왜
이렇게 사람이 많냐고 물어보니까
인스타그램이나 틱톡을 보고 오 경우가
많대요 관광 왔다가 프로필 사진 찍는
경우도 많다라고 하더라고요 이렇게
SNS 발달되면서이 이면에 있는 이런
상권까지 활성화될 수 있다라고 좀
느꼈고
그네 그래서 첫 번째 매각 사례인데
이건 올해 340억 원에 매각된
사례입니다 그래서 원래 2021년도에
약 100억 원에 매입한 부지인데
엄청 큰 주택이었는데 이건 뭐 를
멸실하고 지하 2층에 지상 8층
규모로 신축을 했습니다 그래서 면인데
불구하고 용적률을 최대한 받아서 꽉
채워서 지우긴 했는데 이렇게 이면에
금액대 큰게 팔리는게 되게 좀 놀랍긴
했어요 뭐 물론 이제 여기랑도 가깝고
뭐 건물 면적이나 이런게 너무 좋긴
하는데 이제 건물이 좀 되게 잘
보이는 곳에 있긴 하지만 금액대가
이렇게 300억대 넘는 건물들이
이렇게 팔리는 거에 좀 놀래긴
했습니다 근데 사실 강남이니 이제 좀
이렇게 큰 금액 대도 매각이 되는
거지 다른 지역 같은 경우에는이면 데
100억만 넘어가도 좀 안 팔리는
경우가 되게 많거든요 그래서 좀
저는이 사례를 보면서 아 300억
대도 이렇게 이면에 좀 팔리는구나 또
그렇게 놀랐었고 그리 무엇보다 용도
지역이 3종 일반 주거 지역이에요
그니까 상업지가 아닙니다 상업지가
아닌데도 불구하고 340억 원의
매각이 됐어요 그게 되게 좀
놀라웠는데 아무튼 첫 번째 매각사례
같은 경우에는 낡은 주택을 매입해서
이렇게 꽉 채워서 지으니까 높은
금액에 매각된 그런 사례라고 보시면
될 거 같습니다네 그리고 두 번째
매각 사례는 상업지에 있는 매각
사례예요 2022년도에 낡은 건물을
250억 원에 매입해서 지하 1층
지상 10층 규모로 신축한 빌딩입니다
그래서 신축하다 마자 진짜 원가도 안
남기게 매각을 했어요 305억 원에
매각을 했고 아마 신축비 세금이랑
이런 거 좀 감안하면 정말 원가의
매각한 그런 사례입니다 그래서 이거
같은 경우에는 대지가 150평 정도
되고 연면적이 약 한 600평 정도
됩니다 지금 이게 용적률을 보통 일반
상업지 하면은 800% 아지 받긴
하지만 지금 이거 같은 경우에는
용적률을 다 받지 지 않았어요 그
이유가 뭐냐면 이런 테 난로의 4m
건물 같은 경우에는 연면적을 600평
밖에 못 짓는 지구단위 계획이
있습니다 상업지 아고 무조건 다 올릴
수 있는게 아니라 지구 단위계획
내용들을 잘 확인하셔야 돼요 그래서이
건물도 더 올릴 수 있지만 지구
단위계획 때문에 600병 아지 지은
그런 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다네 그래서 정리를 해 보면
앞서 설명드렸던 거는 삼종 일반 주거
지역이고 그리고 지금 말씀드렸던 건
일반 상업 지역입니다 연면적은 거의
비슷하고 지금 종은 340억 일반
상업지는 305억 있데 저
개인적으로는 저는 그 35억에 그
일반 상업지가 좀 더 낫지 않나
그렇게 생각을 합니다 역삼역 상권을
총네 가지로 좀 분류를 해 보자면 어
역삼역 기준으로 이제 11시 방향
국기원 쪽은 언덕길이 되게 심해요 그
이면까지 이제 상권이 형성되 있고
오르막길로 올라갈수록 주택을 오피스로
개조해서 쓰는 그런 오피스가 되게
많이 있는데 거기 위쪽에는 상권이
없습니다 그리고 이제 용도 지역도
일종 일반도 있지만 일종 전용도 있
있어요 거기 올라갈수록 상권이 있거나
뭐 오피스 수요가 많거나 그렇지
않습니다 그리고 이제 충형 교회 쪽
역삼역 기준으로 이제 두시 방향 쪽
이쪽은 이제 일종 일반 주거
지역이에요 건물들이 대부분 다 이제
높지 않고 바로이면 쪽은 그래도
상권이 좀 상업지가 형성이 돼 있긴
하지만 그 안쪽에는 원룸이라는 이런
주거 시설이 좀 많이 발달되어
있습니다 그리고 이제 역삼역 기준으로
7시 쪽은 역삼역이랑 거리도 멀지도
않고 상권도 좀 활발히 형성돼 있고
안쪽은 이게 도로 정비가 좀 잘 안
돼 있어 있어 가지고 여기 상권보다는
좀 강남역 쪽에 상권이 더 좋습니다
이면까지도 좀 상권이 많이 형성되어
있고 그리고 역삼역 기준으로 지금
5시 쪽 이쪽은 바로 면에만 상권이
있고 나머지는 다 이제 오피스로 이런
임대가 되어 있습니다 그리고 이제
땅의 크기가 대부분 좀 큰 것들이
많거든요 한 100평 정도 되는
건물들이 많아서 거기는 상권보다는 좀
오피스로 많이 좀 밀집되어 있다라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다 그리고 이제
역삼역 상권의 미래 전망을 좀
말씀드리면 테란로 변의 이런 프라잉크
빌딩들은 공실이 없습니다 그 정도로
임대 상황이 너무 좋아요 뉴스를 좀
찾아보면 공실률이 막 5% 이내입니다
여기 이면에 있는 작은 규모의 빌딩
같은 경우에는 5% 이내가 아니에요
공실률이 더 높습니다 좀 애매한 배우
상권이나 아니면 애매한 오피스
상권보다는 이렇게 좀 탄탄한 오피스가
좀 밀집되어 있는 곳이 상권으로 좀
안전하다고 생각합니다 저희도 이제
역사력 근처에 있었고 뭐 거기서 이제
요식업 하시는 분들이 이렇게 만나다
보면 주말에 장사가 안 되긴 하지만
평일로 커버가 될 정도로 평일 장사가
너무 잘 된다라고 합니다 그리고
상업지다 보니까 이제 유흥업소 허가가
나오기 때문에 그 유흥 상권까지 같이
이어진 이런 상권이 되게 좀
탄탄하다고 생각하거든요 그리고 이제
역삼역 인근이 스타트업 거리라고 해서
역삼로 쪽에 이제 형성이 좀 돼
있어요 그러면서 여기 오피스 수유가
좀 많아졌습니다 근데 여러분들이
아셔야 될게 역삼 로에서 도공 로까지
가면 여기가 이제 여기 없어요
안쪽으로 더 들어가면 오피스 공실률이
좀 되게 높아져요 여기랑 아무래도
거리가 되게 높 다 보니까 역삼역
상권을 투자하실 때는 반드시 좀
역과의 거리라는 진입하기 얼마나 편한
거라든지 이런 것들을 좀 따져서
꼼꼼히 투자해 보실 필요가 있습니다
무조건 역삼역 상권이 다 잘된다 그런
건 아니에요 어 일단 좀 정리를 해
보자면 역삼 역 상권은 오피스 수요도
탄탄하고 매력적인 상권이든 하지만
주말에 이제 사람이 없기 때문에
평일로 이루어진 그런 상권입니다이
부분은 반드시 기억하셨다가 역사력
상권을 투자하였으며
다음 시간에 뵙겠습니다 감사합니다
[음악]